it's been 22 years since the matrix
changed cinema forever time is always
against us and a lot has changed since
1999. let's take a look at the crazy
behind the scenes of the matrix
resurrections where the stunts are
bigger the actors wiser and the
creativity is as innovative as ever
check it out if i haven't lost my mind
does that mean
number one even 18 years later he still
knows kung fu keanu reeves co-stars look
to him as a teacher because he has a
strong understanding of story even in
action sequences sometimes movies can be
swamped with unnecessary explosions and
fight scenes but not the matrix so good
at finding the arc of the fight
number two do you think they fire proof
the costumes check out these stunts
where the actors get up close and
personal with the pyrotechnics that's a
little too close for comfort number
three holding hands as they jumped
definitely helped with the fear
keanu and carrie anne moss both had to
learn to control their fear to jump off
of a 46-story building you're really
gonna do this what are you gonna do and
i was like yeah they jumped and then
they did it at least 18 more times
number four that's going to hurt in the
morning
after 18 years keanu returned to stunt
work with relative ease but he found
that the biggest struggle was that the
recovery process takes much longer than
it used to
be
number five this one reminds us of a
parade float check out the motorcycle
rig they created for this shot
number six ice cream you scream we all
scream for
fill in the blank we're wondering if
they hid behind a secret name to stop
the flood of auditions the flood of fans
or both
because project ice cream still sounds
appealing enough to be a draw for
starving artists see what we did there
i'm sorry about this number seven ever
meet with an old friend and it feels
like no time has passed
since it's been so long since the last
movie the actors come at it with 20 more
years of experience
in a sweet spot where they're not too
old but just enough to be a bit world
weary and yet they still connected as if
no time had passed just felt effortless
neo and trinity is like we're still just
in the beginning
number eight at least they didn't rely
on aging tech jada pinkett smith spent
five hours in the makeup chair to land
this look she loved that it gave her the
opportunity to really immerse herself in
another version of naobi i wanna bring
niobi back number nine lawrence
fishburne wasn't trying to dodge this
movie
he simply wasn't asked back surprising
given how memorable his part is and the
character is returning but they've
casted a younger actor yaya abdulmatine
ii to play morpheus so that's probably
the reason as they are messing with age
in this movie for sure
but it worked because here we are
number 10 this might not be a healthy
relationship he loves it lana wachowski
is obsessed with natural light the
timing of sunrises and sunsets were
crucial to filming she finds utilizing
the natural light really advances
storytelling
number 11
old is new again wachowski had to
refrain from repeating shots from past
movies she didn't want to copy what
she'd already done given she's grown as
an artist over the years but she didn't
want to bring them back for nostalgia
sake so the challenge was to repeat
shots but make them fresh at the same
time
number 12. why go backwards when there's
so much yet to be discovered ahead lana
took on directing resurrections by
herself this time around because her
sister lily wachowski didn't come back
due to being completely exhausted by her
other projects she just did cloud atlas
jupiter ascending and the first season
of sense8 but that may have been more of
an excuse she was towards in her career
expressly unappealing as she put it
number 13. free helicopters sweet venom
let there be carnage was filming at the
same time as resurrections so the matrix
helicopters can be seen in venom maybe
it's all part of one big plot to tie the
universes together like a certain mcu
movie is doing right now
but we doubt it
number 14
characters truly exist in the minds of
their creators wachowski's parents
passed away less than a year apart she
was laying in bed in tears when she
realized if she couldn't have them she
could have neo and trinity the two most
important characters in her life the
matrix changed our lives
let's hope resurrections can shake up
cinema again there's nothing better than
a movie that challenges your perception
of the world have you ever experienced
anything that made you question your own
reality let us know in the comments and
thanks for watching